hey everyone i'm shamlee and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on what is hyper ledger in this video
we are going to cover all important
concepts and components related to
hyperledger
first we will understand what is
hyperledger
then we will explore the history of
hyperledger
then we will understand goals of
hyperledger
after that we will look into the layers
of hyperledger technology
after which we will explore
organizational architecture of
hyperledger
then we will understand how hyperledger
works
and at the last we will explore other
hyperledger tools and projects
so without much delay let's get started
with the video
first let's understand what is
hyperledger
hyperledger is an open source community
that offers
and focuses on developing suitable
frameworks
tools and libraries for enterprise grade
blockchain deployments
and builds open source blockchains and
related applications for use across
various industries
the linux foundation hosts this global
collaboration
which comprises professionals in finance
banking
the internet supply chains manufacturing
and technology as well built under
technical governance
and open collaboration individual
developers
service and solution providers
government associations
corporate members and end users are all
encouraged to get
involved in the creation and marketing
of this game-changing innovations
well that makes me wonder how have
pleasure came into existence
let's die down and explore the history
of hyperledger
the hyperledger project was announced by
the linux foundation
in 2015 a year before it was released
the hyperledger project's executive
director brian
bellendorf also claimed that the
hyperledger project would never create
its own cryptocurrency the project began
accepting
submissions for the incubation of code
bases and other code element
technologies in 2016.
hyperledger fabric and lip consensus
were
two of the first blockchain framework
code bases to be accepted
later saw two intel's distributed ledger
was incubated
now let's move to the goals of
hyperledger
first is to facilitate commercial
transaction
create enterprise grade open source
distributed ledger
frameworks and code bases
second is to provide infrastructure that
is impartial
open and community driven with technical
and corporate
governance third is to develop
blockchain
and shared ledger pocs application cases
field trails and deployments build
technical communities
fourth is to educate the general
audience on the blockchain's
technology's
market potential fifth is
to promote our community of communities
by utilizing a toolkit approach
that includes a variety of platforms and
framework
now let's understand the technology
layer of hyperledger
hyperledger employs the following
essential business components in its
architecture
first is the consensus layer it is in
charge of reaching an agreement
on the order and verifying the accuracy
of the blog's transactions
then comes the smart contract layer
which is in charge of processing
transaction requests
and only authorizing transactions that
are valid
after that is the communication layer
peer-to-peer message
transit is handled by the communication
layer
then comes identity management services
these are required for maintaining and
validating user
and system identities as well as
creating trust on the blockchain
and at the end comes the api or
application programming interface
external programs and clients can
interact with the blockchain using the
api
now let's have a look at the
organizational architecture
of hyperledger essentially hyperledger
enables the development of various
blockchain-based systems
and applications for industrial use by
providing the necessary infrastructure
and standards it acts more like a hub
bringing together numerous blockchain
based projects
and tools that follow established design
philosophy
hyperledger's architecture can be
broadly divided into three main
components
which is apis sdks
and clis apis or application programming
interface
include membership services which is a
set of cryptographic certificates
that defines the organization by itself
every pair or order needs this type of
certificate
which consists of some common properties
that signifies
that whether the peer or the order
belongs to the same organization
a pair which is a part of the same
membership services can communicate with
each other but peers from other
organizations cannot communicate with
each other
sdks or software development kits
include
blockchain and transaction layer which
constitutes the core code of the
blockchain
it consists of the consensus algorithm
which helps to make the final decision
on the validation of every transaction
it also consists of distributed ledger
as well as legit storage
which contains all details regarding the
transactions
made 1 and also lastly known status of
each transaction
it has a peer-to-peer protocol used to
communicate between the nodes
on the network clies a command line
interface consists of chain code which
is a layer of logical programming
which consists of the business logic
required to run
in operation on the hyperledger now that
we know all about hyperledger structure
and goals let's understand how
hyperledger works
let's take an example of two friends
alex and sarah
who wants to perform a hyperledger
transaction
sarah runs a bakery and wants to send a
birthday cake to alex
as per his request on the sarah's bakery
app now sarah looks for his address
on her application which sends a query
to the membership services of the
application and validates transaction of
only
directly affiliated peers to the
application
now our application searches for alex's
membership on the membership services
of that particular application for
validation
now after that hyperledger connects both
parties
alex and sarah both of them will now
generate a result which
needs to be the same for the transaction
to be validated on the two-party
agreement
now the validated transaction is then
sent to the consensus cloud for placing
orders
and these orders are then sent to the
connected peers
and then being verified by them
according to the ledger once it is
approved by the consensus cloud
alex finally receives his birthday cake
and then the transaction is committed to
the ledger
now let's have a look at some other
hyperledger tools and projects
hyperledger fabric hyperledger sawtooth
high pleasure ayurva hyperledger indie
hyperlogic basu hyperledger caliper
hyperledger explorer hyperledger cello
and hyperledger burrow are a few
hyperledger tools and projects
introduced after the origin of
hyperledger in 2016.
well this is all about hyperledger we
almost reached the end of this video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on what is
hyperledger
and learn something new from it if you
like this video
then please do hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates
and videos from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here